[音楽]
こんにちは
まず簡単に皆さんに質問をさせてください
今ここ大阪そして関西に住まれている方
手を挙げてください
ありがとうございます
では次にいまから7年後
ここ大阪そして関西におそらく自分が住んでいるだろうな
そう思われる方ってをあげてください
ありがとうございます
今日はここ大阪そして関西の未来についてお話ししていきたいとおもいます
自己紹介が遅れました
若造の冨田祐平です
そうです僕は若造です
今僕は若造というメンバーの一員として仲間たちと
ある大きなチャレンジをしています
若造
若造は2025年大阪関西への挽歌杭打ちを若者から盛り上げ
万博を若者から作っていくそのために結成された
ランダーサーティーの学生団体です
万博を若者から作る
ここから若造という言葉ができています
皆さんはわんぱくっと聞いて何をイメージするでしょうか
万博うっと聞いてこの太陽の塔をイメージした方も多かったのではないでしょうか
太陽の塔これは1970年
ここ大阪で万博が開催された時に建てられ今でも残っています
実際にこの太陽の塔は万博の象徴として認識されているのではないでしょうか
1970年今から約50年前になります
もちろん僕は生まれていません
ちょうど自分の父親が生まれた年になります
しかしこの太陽の塔通して僕はここ大阪で1970年に万博が開催されたという歴史を
することができます
1970年大阪万博では月の石をはじめとした世界の最先端の技術や芸術作品が展示さ
れました
その展示方であった1970年の大阪万博に対して2025年の今誘致が行われている
万博では課題解決型の万博となります
っていうのは命輝く未来社会
そして国連が掲げる sdg 頭が達成された社会を目指しています
sdg ずは世界を変えるための17の目標
課題解決型の万博を開催するにあたって
私たちには世界を変えるために未来について考えることが求められています
7年後の社会に向けてどんな社会になっていくのか
そしてどんな社会にしたいのか
このどんな社会にしたいのかは僕たち若者に強く考えることを求められています
僕は今大阪を変え日本を変えそして世界を変えたりそんな思いで
若造の仲間たちと活動に取り組んでいます
話は変わって
この可愛らしい少年は一体誰でしょう
この可愛らしい少年は小学生時代の奥です
注目していただきたいのはこの可愛らしい少年がかぶっている帽子です
小学生時代の僕は野球が大好きで
外で友達と野球をして家に帰っては野球を見る
その毎日を繰り返していました
そんな僕にとってのスーパースターが1人いました
それがこの帽子のシアトルマリナーズに所属していた
イチロー選手です
疲労選手は当時メジャーでのシーズン最多安打記録
世界記録を更新するなどの活躍で当時アメリカに行ったことすらなかった
僕でもこの人はすごい人や
世界中の人たちに夢と感動を与えている人がいい
そう感じた記憶があります
僕もイチロー選手みたいな野球選手になれたら
世界中の人に夢を与えて
世界中の人たちに感動を与えられる
そう考えました
そしてイチロー選手のモデルのパッドを買って毎日練習してきた記憶があります
しかし残念なことに僕はイチロー選手とはかけ離れて全然野球をうまくなることができ
ませんでした
一時期は野球を左になりかけたこともあるくらいです
自分の運動神経では誰にも感動なんて与えられない
運動神経は
全然優れていない僕でしたが
周りの子達に比べて勉強が出来ました
正直この小学校の中では自分が一番賢い
そう考えていましたさ
なぜかそして僕は周りの子たちに将来は総理大臣になる
そう宣言をしましたん
勉強を頑張っていたら自然と描く慣れてそして総理大臣になれてそんな日本のリーダー
になれる
おそらくそう考えていた時点で全然賢くはなかったのかもしれませんが僕は当時の僕は
純粋にそう考えていました
しかし現実を突きつけられます
実際僕は大学受験でも一度失敗を経験していますしこの大阪大学に入学できたと思う
自分よりも賢い子なんて周りにたくさんいるって言うことに
じゅうじゅう気づかされてきました
結局自分が得意だと思っていた勉強でも誰にも感動なんて与えられない
じゃあどうしたらいいんだ
大学生になった僕は会社機ということに興味を持つようになっていましたん
何か凄い企業をつくってアイディアを通して人々に価値を与える
そんなことができたらそれって世界を変えられてるんじゃないか
そう考えるようになっていました
実際に学生生活の中で学部の友人を誘って自分たちのアイデアを形にして世の中に発信
しようとしました
しかし当時プログラミングのスキルを持っていなかった自分たちにとって
アイディアを形にする
ここがとても難しくてうまくいきませんでした
じゃあいったい世界はどうやったら変えられるでしょうか
いやこんなポンコツな大学生の自分に何も世界なんて変えられない
そう考えちゃいました
世界を変える
僕は今日この言葉を繰り返してきました
皆さんにとって世界を変えるとはどういうことを意味する言葉ですか
僕にとって世界を変えるとはこれまで何かをクリエイティブすること何かを作り出す
こと
そう考えていました
世界を驚かせる記録を作ったイチロー選手
日本の全員にとってより新しい日本を作っていく総理大臣
そしてまたこの世の中にない新しいアイディアで人々に価値を届ける
経営者の人たち
全員何かを作り出しているだから自分も何かを作り出さなければ世界は変えられてい
ない
そんな風に考えていました
ここで少し僕は大阪大学経済学部で学ぶ学生です
ですので簡単に皆さんと一緒に経済のお勉強をしたいと思います
とはいっても需要供給曲線というグラフを一度は見たことや
なかったことがあると思うので簡単に
まず供給曲線
これは生産者はあるモノやサービスの価格が上がれば上がるほどどんどん生産をしよう
とするということを表しています
次に
需要曲線
これは消費者はあるモノやサービスが安くなればなるほどどんどん商品をしようとする
ということを表しています
この時
供給量が需要量を上回った状態
つまりものが余ってしまっているときにはそのものの証ジョンテの価格は下がります
逆に需要量が表九量を上回っているとき
つまりものが足りなくなってしまっているときはそのものの市場での価格は上がります
このグラフを大学に入って改めて
は何の時に僕は一つふと気づいたことがありました
世の中には生産者がいて消費者がいる
たとえ生産者がどれだけ素晴らしいものを作っている
そう思っていたとしても消費者がそのものを欲しいと思わなければそのものの市場での
価値というのは上がらないんだ
そんなすごく当たり前のことに気づきました
オフが皆さんにお話ししたいことは世界を変えるのは良き消費者になることから始まる
のかもしれない
ということです
僕が考える良き消費者になるためには大きく二つの力が必要だと考えています
ひとつは自分の感性を大切にできる
そしてその次に発疹ができる
この2つの力を持っている人は良き消費者になれると考えています
ところでみなさんこの大阪大学の近くにある
石橋の居酒屋さんいったいどれくらい知っているでしょうか
正直僕もここに帰ってもうすぐ4年になるんですが
指折り数えるぐらいしか知らないと思います
実際に大学生活を思い返してみてもいつもの友達といつも安くてそこそこ美味しい
チェーン店の居酒屋さんに行っていた記憶ばかりです
ですがあるとき僕の友人が
突然の事ですめっちゃ美味しい居酒屋さんおいしい場所で見つけたから一緒に行こうや
そんな風に沿ってくれました
そして実際に連れて行ってもらうとその店は僕がいつも石橋で通っていた店とは
ちょっと外れた細い道にある
ボロボロ府のビルの中に入っている看板は特に出ていない1件のお好み焼き屋さんでし
た
そして実際にそこに入ってメニューを開いて皆見るといつもそのいっていたチェーン店
の居酒屋さんよりも圧倒的に高かったです
そこで少し僕は友人を疑ってしまっていつもの癖で
スマートフォンを取り出してネットでそのお店の評判を調べてしまいました
そのお店の評価は5段階評価で3.0
完全に僕はその友人を疑いました
しかし結論としてはそこがお好み焼き屋さんの味はとても美味しかったです
そして何よりその目の前で焼いてくれて
大阪ならではの会話を交えたサービスエースにあふれたお店でした
結果として
そのいつも言っていた居酒屋さんチェーン店の居酒屋さんよりも僕にとってはその
お好み焼き屋さんの方が満足度が高かったのです
ここで僕が言いたいことはその僕を
お好み焼き屋さんに連れて行ってくれた友人は僕が言う良き消費者だったのかもしれ
ません
その友人がいなければおそらく僕は普段の居酒屋さチェーン店の居酒屋さんよりも高い
ボロボロのビルに入っている看板のない食べログの評価が3.0のお店に足を運ぶこと
はなかったと思います
私たちは
つい何かを無意識的に選択してしまう事が増えているような気がします
みんなが使っているからみんながいいと言っているから
それが先行しすぎているような気がします
自分が8を感じるものは何なのか
自分が8を感じるものはどこにあるのか
そんな自分の感性を大切にする
そしてそれを自分の言葉で発信をしてみる
誰か友達にオススメをしてみる
もしくは特定の誰かではなくとも今の時代 sns を使って自分の言葉で発信をして
みる
その発信が次の良き消費者を生むことにつながるかもしれない
そう考えるのです
そして容器消費者になれば4基生産者と一緒に何かをクリエイティブすることがハロー
だと思います
逆にクリエイティブは4基生産者だけでは生まれず
4基生産者と良き消費者が一緒になって生まれるものだと考えます
また
自分が感じることを素直に世の中に発信してみる
周りの目は気にせずに発信をしてしまう
これって若者だからこそできることだと僕は考えています
そんな思いから僕は昨年万博の誘致活動が化で若者の思いを発信できるサイトを
立ち上げました
このサイトでは万博のマスコットキャラクターのアイディアや自分たち若者の未来に
対する
アイディア意見お気軽に投稿することができるサイトです
投稿されたアイディアの合計は2025にも及びました
たとえ一つ一つが小さなアイディアだったとしても
僕たちはそのアイディア全体の中から自分たちが作りたい
社会の未来像を描くことができました
そして
万博家が決まる今年もっと世界に向けて発信する場所をつくりたいそんな思いで
一つの世界一つの地球儀を作っています
この地球儀では世界の若者が sdg ずに対してどんな意見を持っているのかを知る
ことができます
地球の裏側にいる若者が今どんなことを考えているのか
これってに市場の中でなかなか考えることはないと思います
しかしに万博という機会があるからこそ私たちは地球の裏側の若者の声に少し耳を傾け
てみる
4基商事者となってみることができると思います
逆に自分たちが発信をして世界の人たちに受け止めてもらう
消費をしてもらう
そんなチャンスだと考えています
僕たちは画像は今この世界の若者の発信から作られる世界
これを一つのパビリオンとして表現することを目指しています
このパビリオンが2025年万博の象徴となり
聞いては世界の若者の象徴となることを目指しています
世界は変えられる
何か世界を変えるためには自分の考え方を劇的に変化させる必要はないのかもしれませ
ん
普段自分が感じるものにもっともっと素直になっていくべきなのかもしれません
自分が感じる価値は何なのか
自分が感じる価値はどこにあるのか
そしてそれがどんなに些細なことでもいいので世の中に発信をしてみる
きっと共感してくれる人が見つかると思います
あなたの作りたい社会って何ですか
想像出来る未来は実現できる
僕はそう考えています
若者が作りたい社会を一緒に想像して一緒に作っていきましょう
私たち若者が作りたい社会をつくる
ありがとうございました大
[拍手]